do you think of as an interesting idea
this thought experiment that will live
in a simulation
and in general do you think we'll live
in a simulation
so the nick bostrom's idea about the
simulation
is typically
couched in a physicalist framework yes
so there is the bottom level
there's some programmer in this physical
spacetime and they have a computer that
they've programmed really cleverly where
they've created conscious entities
so you have the hard problem of
consciousness right the standard hard
problem how could a computer simulation
create a constant
which isn't explained by that simulation
theory but then the idea is that the
next level the the entities that are
from the
that are
created in the first level simulation
then can write their own simulations and
you get this this nesting
so
so the idea that um this is a simulation
is fine
but the idea that it starts with a
physical space i think
is important
there's different properties here the
the partial rendering and to me that's
the interesting idea
is not whether the entirety of the
universe is simulated but how
efficiently can you
create interfaces that are convincing to
all
other entities that can appreciate such
interfaces
how little does it take
because you said like partial rendering
or like temporal
affirmal rendering of stuff
only render the tree falling in the
forest when there's somebody there to
see it
it's interesting
to think how can you do that super
efficiently without having to render
everything and that to me is one
perspective on the simulation just like
it is with video games right where a
video game doesn't have to render every
single thing it's just the thing that
the observer is looking at
right there is actually that's a
very nice question and there's
whole groups of researchers that are
actually studying in virtual reality
what
what is the sort of minimal
requirements on this system what how
does it have to operate to give you an
immersion experience to give you the
feeling that you have a body to to get
you to take it real and there's actually
a lot of really good work on that right
now and it turns out it doesn't take
that much you do need to get the
perception action loop
tight and
you have to
give them the perceptions that they're
expecting if you want them to but if you
you you can
lead them along if you give them
perceptions that are close to what
they're expecting you can then maybe
move their reality around a bit yeah
it's a tricky engineering problem
especially when you're trying to create
a product
that costs little but that's i it feels
like an engineering problem not a deeply
scientific problem
um
or meaning obviously it's a scientific
problem but as a scientific problem it's
not that difficult to trick us
uh descendants of apes but here's here's
a
case for just us you know our own this
is a virtual reality that we're
experiencing right now so
here's something you can try for
yourself
if you just close your eyes
and look at
your experience in front of you to be
aware of your experience in front of you
what you experience is just like a
modeled
dark gray but there's all sort of
there's some dynamics to it but it's
just dark gray
but now i ask you
instead of having your attention
forward
put your attention backward what is it
like behind you with your eyes closed
and there
it's like
nothing
it's real
so
what is going on here what
what am i experiencing back there
it's bright well it's i i don't know if
it's nothing it's it's like i guess it's
the absence of it's not even like
darkness or something it's it it's not
even darkness
there's no there's no
qualia to it and yet there is a sense of
being
and that's the interesting thing there's
a sense of being back so i closed my
i put my attention forward i just i have
the quality of a gray model thing but
when i put my attention backward there's
no quality at all but there is a sense
of being yeah
i i personally
uh now you haven't been to that side of
the room i have been to that side of the
room so for me memories i start
um i start
playing the engine of memory replay
which is like i i take myself back in
time and think about that place where i
was hanging out in that part that's what
i see when i'm behind so which that's an
interesting quirk of humans too we're
able to we're collecting these
experiences and we can replay them in
interesting ways whenever we feel like
it and it's almost like being there
but not really but almost
that that's right
and yet we can go our entire lives on
this you're talking about the minimal
thing for vr we can go our entire lives
and not realize that all of my life
it's been like nothing behind me
yeah
we we're not even aware that all of our
lives
if you just just for the just pay
attention close your eyes pay attention
to what's behind me we're like oh holy
smoke it's
scary i mean it's like nothing there's
no quality there at all how did i not
notice that my entire life we're so
immersed in the simulation we buy it so
much yeah i mean uh you could see this
with with children right
with persistence you know you could do
the peekaboo game you can hide from them
and appear
and they're fully tricked and in the
same way we're fully tricked
there's nothing behind us and we assume
there is
that's really interesting
you